il y a parfois des imprévus en politique
mon invité n'avait pas du tout prévu de
devenir député il siège pourtant à
l'Assemblée depuis 2017
[Musique]
bonjour Fabien Lainé bonjour Monsieur
Eric alors tous les chemins mènent à la
politique vous c'est votre baby-sitter
qui vous est amené c'est ça alors
absolument oui effectivement c'était ma
nounou
sur le Bassin d'Arcachon dont je suis
originaire qui dit ma voisine qui nous
gardait à ma soeur et moi et qui m'a qui
s'est présenté aux élections municipales
en 89 et qui donc
m'a associé en fait à son choix
politique à sa volonté de s'investir
pour l'intérêt général et immédiatement
ça m'a plu sur les thèmes municipaux je
devais avoir 13 ans à l'époque et de ce
qui pouvait toucher la jeunesse mais
également appris tout ce qui était
aménagement urbanisme architecture
paysage associé c'est vous faisiez quoi
m'emmener avec elle elle m'en parlait
beaucoup
me donner des cours d'instructions
civique comme on était Lucas
responsabilité on a et c'est vrai que ça
ça rythmé mon adolescence après et
arrivé au lycée tout naturellement j'ai
continué à m'intéresser à la vie
publique et quelques années plus tard
c'est vous qui vous êtes présenté dans
cette même commune Le Teich c'est comme
ça qu'on dit oui une commune à côté
d'Arcachon vous aviez 24 ans tête de
liste municipales alors vous n'avez pas
gagné vous avez siéger dans l'opposition
pendant pendant quelques années et puis
en 2014 vous êtes présenté et vous avez
été élu cette fois mais dans une autre
commune parce que vous aviez déménagé
entre temps vous êtes présentés à
sanguiner vous dites que ce mandat de
maire correspond à votre âme de patron
c'est quelque chose que vous retrouvez
moins dans le mandat de député
expliquez-nous un peu cette idée d'âme
de patron ça veut dire quoi c'est vrai
quand vous êtes Le Maire et j'ai eu la
joie d'être le maire de cette belle
commune de sanguiner dans les Landes où
je suis toujours d'ailleurs élu c'est
vrai que vous prenez des décisions toute
la journée avez-vous services avec vos
élus et donc c'est de l'arbitrage en
permanence bien différent du travail
qu'on va demander à un parlementaire un
parlementaire il est là pour voter et
amender la loi mais également faire du
contrôle parlementaire et faire de
l'influence moi c'est ça on va en parler
on va en parler après marquer vraiment
mais c'est ce côté aux commandes aux
manettes qui vous plaisait
évidemment j'étais directeur commercial
avant et que c'est vrai que je manageais
une équipe commerciale et puis j'avais
des clients et il fallait prendre des
décisions aussi donc le travail de mer
même s'il y a en faveur de l'intérêt
général ma part réellement changé sur ma
façon de manager et ces trois belles
années que j'ai vécu à la tête de
stokomy et vraiment moi j'étais marqué
au début parce qu'en fait vous êtes très
très sollicité par l'administration il y
a un nouveau maire et donc il faut qu'il
se positionne sur plein de choses puis
le maire est également vice président de
l'intercommunalité chez nous quasi
automatiquement donc là aussi à la côté
de commune c'est une belle très attendu
oui Sami habitants 20000 été donc on a
une balnéaire où il y a déjà des
services il y a 100 100 salariés donc
c'est vrai que il faut il faut manager
il faut être à la tête de cette
administration municipale alors vous
étiez très heureux dans ce mandat de mer
on l'a compris mais au législatif de
2017 vous avez accepté de devenir le
suppléant de Geneviève Darius sec à
l'époque vous pensez qu'il y avait un
risque ou une chance je sais pas selon
votre point de vue que vous deveniez
député non mais tout ça a été assez
nouveau moi j'étais le premier maire
avec Lionel cosse lui était chez les
socialistes moi j'étais centriste et on
se met à se tenir Emmanuel Macron fin
2013 pardon 2016 pardon et et les choses
naturellement font qu'on s'aperçoit
qu'il va devenir président de la
République et qu'il va falloir qu'il y
ait des parlementaires en tout cas des
candidats moi je souhaitais que ça soit
Geneviève qui se présente parce que en
fait c'était la mère de Mont-de-Marsan
une politique éminente de notre
département très apprécié et c'est du
reste toujours le cas et donc voilà j'ai
été la voir plusieurs fois Geneviève
vas-y parce que c'est ton tour c'est ta
place elle me disait mais c'est toi qui
l'a soutenu au tout début donc tu es
légitime pour y aller je vais être élu
maire trois ans avant la ville était en
chantier j'avais lancé plein de projets
je me voyais pas partir à l'Assemblée
nationale bon et donc elle a accepté d'y
aller et quand elle me l'a demandé c'est
naturellement j'ai dit oui alors
vous pouvez devenir ministre parce que
non elle pensait pas l'être est-ce que
ça s'est passé comme ça à peine élu elle
a été nommée ministre et elle a depuis
pas quitté le gouvernement donc vous
avez siéger en continu depuis parce
qu'elle a été réélu en 2022 avec
toujours vous comme suppléant mais à
n'importe quel moment elle peut
redevenir députée
au prochain remaniement elle n'est plus
ministre est-ce que ça fait pas de vous
un peu un député en sursis comment on
vit ça ça fait je suis le plus ancien
aujourd'hui suppléant siègeant de ce que
je sais et donc on apprend à vivre avec
le sursis mais c'est comme ça que ça a
été convenu je serai sûrement un peu
nostalgique de quitter l'assemblée
nationale parce que j'y ai pris mes
marques depuis six ans et en donnant du
sens à mon engagement au niveau national
et également local mais avec beaucoup de
bonheur je retrouvais la mairie aussi
alors vous avez une formule qui a retenu
mon attention vous dites qu'un député
c'est un influenceur
du coup je suis allé voir à quoi
ressemblait vos réseaux sociaux et sur
Instagram je suis tombé sur ça
[Musique]
j'aime bien les musiques je crois que
c'est Star Wars sur l'examen de la loi
de programmation militaire mais on est
d'accord là vous n'êtes pas un
influenceur au sens classique du terme
qu'est-ce que vous entendez par député
influenceur deux choses déjà quand vous
retrouvez ici moi ce qui m'a marqué dès
les premiers jours c'est en fait là vous
prenez plus de décisions et c'est pas ce
qu'on vous demande on vous demande c'est
de vous représenter votre territoire
de de d'apporter de la plus-value à au
travail législatif il y a des
amendements mais également via des
rapports donc vous allez faire un
travail un peu plus universitaire je
voudrais dire ça c'est l'autre voler
après que mais en tout cas vous allez
faire un travail de fond pour influencer
le travail législatif c'est pour ça que
je parlais d'influenceurs et en même
temps moi ce que j'ai vu c'est que
nos administrés
nos électeurs nos citoyens connaissent
mal le travail du parlementaire comme
moi je pouvais mal connaître avant de
l'être et je me suis mis pour modeste
mission mais au moins à l'endroit de là
où je suis élu de rendre compte en
permanence ce que je fais et en quoi
consiste mon mon travail quotidien de
parlementaire qu'il s'agisse de
représenter les territoires mais
également de mon action à la commission
de la défense alors vous dites aussi
qu'un député doit être un universitaire
c'est pour ça que quand vous avez
commencé à siéger à l'Assemblée vous
avez pris des cours d'anglais vous avez
suivi une formation à l'ENA sur les
questions de géopolitiques je crois que
maintenant vous êtes vous suivez les
cours de l'iaedn l'Institut des hautes
études de la Défense nationale c'est ça
le côté universitaire mais vous avez le
devoir moi j'ai pas fait de longues
études j'ai des constructeurs de maison
individuelles vous imaginez bien que
quand vous retrouvez à siégé dans des
assemblées
politiques qui traite des questions de
défense de géopolitique que je sais
aussi à l'Assemblée parlementaire de
l'OTAN vous le devoir de vous former sur
des sujets d'être vraiment au point
l'anglais parce qu'effectivement quand
vous êtes à la défense vous avez
beaucoup
vous avez beaucoup de rencontres avec
nos partenaires étrangers européens mais
pas que vous voyagez vous représentez le
pays et à l'Assemblée parlementaire même
si le français et langue officielle en
off quand vous retrouvez avec des
parlementaires notamment allemands pour
parler du SCAF du système urbain le
futur il faut être à guéri il faut être
aguerri techniquement sur le forum mais
également sur la forme à l'Assemblée
donc vous êtes spécialisé sur les
questions de défense vous l'avez dit il
faut dire que vous avez deux bases
aériennes et un centre de tir de
missiles sur votre circonscription et
puis sur la chasse qui est encore
beaucoup pratique et dans les langues
dans les Landes pardon est-ce qu'on peut
être élu député des Landes si on n'est
pas chasseur ou si on est contre la
chasse
alors moi je suis très favorable à
chasse n'étant pas chasseur mais mon
père l'été et toute ma famille il est
depuis des gazons depuis très longtemps
donc on a vraiment ça dans notre ADN les
députés qui sont contre la chasse vous
en connaissez dans l'histoire politique
des Landes je pense que il faut pas long
feu c'est ça mais
moi j'ai cette attachement à ma terre
vous êtes chasseur vous avez oui parce
que moi les chasseurs c'est pas que
c'est pas que l'acte synégétique c'est
au côté de contemplation de la nature
d'être vigiles de l'environnement parce
que pouvoir vous la renvoie sur la photo
bigano qui est un chasseur de gibier
d'eau de sanguiner mais mais c'est un
écologiste qui prend soin de de nos
milieux parce que
dégradation de pollution de chasse ce
sont ces gens qui vont nous le dire
uniquement parce que il y a beaucoup de
chasseurs dans les Landes c'est pas
c'est pas ça se résume pas ça votre
engagement pour la chasse moi j'aime
beaucoup l'environnement et toutes les
questions qui touchent autour de la
biodiversité et donc là on est au cœur
du réacteur sur la université c'est à
dire que j'ai toujours plaidé pour
qu'ils ne vision scientifique de la
chasse et non pas affective c'est à dire
que l'évolution des espèces et en
fonction de ça effectivement on a des
quotas qu'on peut chasser ou pas et on
rationalise un peu les choses et en même
temps c'est quand même cette beauté de
la nature et chez nous elle est très
présente avec la plus grande forêt
d'Europe qui est dans les Landes donc
voilà c'est la chasse c'est aussi tout
ça et nos traditions séculaires alors en
pratique aussi beaucoup la corrida dans
votre circonscription dans votre
département des Landes il vous arrive
aussi d'aller en voir vous êtes un peu
un aficionado c'est donc logiquement que
vous êtes opposé à la proposition de loi
d'americ Caron qui voulait abolir la
corrida mais ce qui a retenu mon
attention c'est la façon dont vous êtes
justifié dans un communiqué vous avez
dit en tant qu'élu de la nation ce n'est
pas mon avis personnel qui compte mais
bien celui des concitoyens que je suis
censé écouter et représenté ça veut dire
quoi que votre avis il compte pas vos
idées vos valeurs le programme sur
lequel vous avez été lu ça passe après
ce que pense vos électeurs comment vous
concevez les choses la corrida c'est
quelque chose qui fait partie de
l'identité de ma région et y toucher et
quand on est député parisien et qu'on
veut interdire aux gens du Sud-Ouest
leur pratique c'est un irritant et donc
là je définir votre mandat de député
votre conception du mandat de député on
a l'impression que ce que pense vos
électeurs passent avant ce que vous vous
pensez par exemple quand vous défendez
l'exploitation du pétrole au-delà de
2040 parce que vous avez un gisement de
pétrole sur votre territoire et vous
avez des engagements écolos par ailleurs
dans votre mandat de député ça peut
donner le sentiment que vous portez des
idées qui sont pas forcément d'être
contradictoires ça se voudriez dire en
harmonie avec vos convictions et en fait
non parce que l'affaire du pétrole c'est
de après 2040 moi les 10 et qu'on puisse
continuer à produire du pétrole parce
qu'on en aura besoin et le pétrole qui
produit en France il est trois fois
moins émissive dans son extraction que
celui qu'on importe via le transport et
aussi des techniques d'extraction donc
c'est un choix responsable en matière
d'environnement en plus ce qui
produisent du pétrole chez moi et ils
sont dans la cogénération ça avec nos
quartiers ça chauffe des serres donc
tout ça est beaucoup plus responsable
vous arrivez à inverser les les
arguments c'est parce que j'essaye
d'être rationnel et je pense que l'élu
doit être rationnel avant tout on l'a vu
pendant la crise du covid et souvent on
est parti dans des des délires affectifs
alors que l'idée c'est d'être rassurer
et on est quand on est rationnel on sert
bien l'intérêt général c'est moi ce que
je porte on va passer à notre quiz à
présent si vous le voulez bien alors
l'idée c'est que vous allez devoir
compléter les phrases que je vais vous
proposer que je vais commencer ma
première prise de parole dans
l'hémicycle
je pense qu'ils n'ont entendu que les
voyelles puisque j'étais tellement ému
il y avait plus les consonnes dans ce au
lieu d'histoire en fait extrêmement
stressé au moment où j'arrivais au
perchoir mais juste avant à la tribune
pardon juste avant ça allait mais là
d'un seul coup grand émotion de ce lieu
dit chargé d'histoire pour comprendre le
jargon des militaires il faut
beaucoup travailler parce qu'il y a
beaucoup d'acronymes il faut se former
il faut beaucoup discuter avec eux et ça
finit par rentrer mais j'en apprends
encore tous les jours enfin quand
Geneviève darrieussec quittera le
gouvernement vous avez déjà plus ou
moins répondu à cette question tout à
l'heure j'aurais le plaisir de de
rentrer chez moi à sanguiner et si le
conseil municipal le souhaite je
reprendrai mes fonctions de mer comme je
m'y étais engagé merci beaucoup Fabien
lené d'être venu dans la politique et
moi
[Musique]